[Musique]
l'idée pourquoi l'été puisque sur ce
point de vue sur le smart sur le web on
peut avoir plusieurs applications avec
de l'actualité et sur la télévision peut
voir d'autres choses aussi puiss book de
tully des journaux ça t'arrive où c'est
vraiment que ce soit interné rarement
qu'est ce que c'est qu'elle situe
consultation interne et un peu de tout
dc sur l'actualité des forums des blogs
si un peu et sur quelles thématiques bas
la médecine le sport est un petit peu la
politique
vraiment fois comment tu étais tout et
confiance à ce que tu lis sur internet
bah je parle beaucoup avec mes parents
et quand je sais que je peux parler tout
à fait que passer avec eux je vois si
c'est vrai ou pas qu'est ce que tu
penses du métier de journaliste ça peut
être bien pour informer les gens mais
après divulguer trop d'informations se
peut inquiéter les gens et faire un peu
de la panique
du coup c'est bien mais il faut pas trop
abuser